Eric we have a question from Chloe
Louisa and Chloe asks what goes into a
successful series pitch and what are
some tips to really sell your ideas so
what I've learned is that a successful
series pitch it focuses on the series
not just the pilot that's one of the big
things because people tend to like come
up with an idea for what's going to
happen in the pilot episode and they
want to pitch that in great detail but
they may not really understand what a
typical episode would look like after
the pilot and so the other thing that
writers tend to do is they feel like oh
I know the long arcs of this show it's
gonna start here and in season 5 it's
gonna be here and these are these things
that are gonna take many many episodes
to play out and while there is a place
for that in a pitch I think writers tend
to air too much on the side writers that
are just kind of starting out on the
side of those kind of long arcs and what
can be more important and as easy for
them to miss is yeah but what is a
typical episode look like what's a
typical 1 hour or half hour of this show
I think that's what the listener is kind
of trying to most understand because
they're picturing something that is
going to be these endless episodes of
hopefully and each episode has to have
its own beginning middle and end and not
just be a small piece of a longer story
it has to have its own story in fact it
probably is gonna have multiple stories
in it because a typical TV episode has
maybe two three four different stories
going on with a different main character
who has a problem or a goal that week
and that's gonna build and escalate over
the course of that half hour or hour at
the end it's going to resolve and so
you're kind of coming up with a template
of what a typical episode looks like
when you come up with a pitch so you
want to be able to communicate that
template in a compelling way so that
they can sort of imagine okay there's
going to be endless hours of this and I
can see the kind of things that are
gonna happen in a typical episode the
kind of problems and conflicts that are
gonna be the grist for stories which
characters are gonna get stories what
are those characters main life issues
problems desires and conflicts that are
gonna lead to stories because a story is
a problem a desire a conflict that
someone is actively trying to resolve
right it's usually building and
complicating and then reaching some sort
of climax but
what's resolved so a lot of it is also
about character is you want obviously
have compelling characters that feel
believable and entertaining and you know
some somewhat original that but they
need something to do they need something
that's gonna create endless hell for
them essentially so what is the hell
that's almost like the biggest question
what puts your characters in hell what's
the thing they're grappling with every
single week I mean ozark the cartel is
gonna kill us unless we do this very
difficult thing and we might get killed
or go to jail trying to do that thing so
it's like figuring out what that is and
that's the main thing you're
communicating there's this big sort of
problematic situation that affects
everyone on this show that everyone's
involved in in some way and then we have
these specific interesting characters
who are part of that with their own
personal problems and conflicts along
the way so understanding all of that and
being able to communicate that to me is
kind of like the core of any pitch for a
series so you're saying most beginning
writers may they want to write let's
just use this as an example the pilot
episode of big little lies but then they
don't figure out all the other episodes
and all the stories and arcs and three
acts that are going to be in those other
episodes yeah it's not that you have to
figure out every episode that's like way
too much work to be doing in advance
like every story in every episode it's
more that you need that sort of
franchise's the word that sometimes use
which is the endlessly repeatable story
generating situation right so you want
to know something about what's happening
in your pilot and something about where
things might be evolving over the course
of say the first season or first and
second season or whatever but almost
more important than that is
understanding how in a typical hour or a
typical half-hour of this series here or
who might hear here's the the main
characters that are mostly going to be
the ones we're following and here's the
kind of stuff they're involved in the
kind of problems that they're trying to
resolve you don't have to know what they
are specifically but you have to kind of
have a sense of what they're made from
you know what's causing stories to
happen you know every week on this show
what is that thing that's that's
creating endless
flic difficulty and a desire to resolve
a problem and that's you know to me
that's the main thing that tells me what
it shows about just like in a feature
film the log line is basically telling
you what's the main problem the main
external difficulty that the person
we're following is trying to resolve
that's really important it's gonna take
the whole movie to resolve it's about
the problem at the center of the story
so it's really the same thing with a
series only it's it's it's got to be
ongoing stories that are gonna go on and
on and on many stories dozens and dozens
even hundreds of stories you want to
feel like this has the potential for
you